this is a production of Cornell
University translate that has the
potential to change final yield and
effect and how we manage our
agricultural acres worldwide today I'm
going to speak to you about how in the
soils lab or looking identify regions of
the wheat genome that implement are
implemented in affecting kernel weight
and size and their potential for being
introduced into elite varieties so
cereal crop yields can simply be modeled
as the spikes for area by the kernels
per spike and by the wait for kernel and
considering the economic importance of
yield there have been countless genetic
associations looking into these
different yield components but there's
been less success in actually
identifying the causal variants and
implementing them in variety x' part of
that is due to the fact that the wheat
genome is very large and hexaploid and
also that yield itself is a quantitative
trait it's controlled by many small
effect variants across the genome and
even these three simplifications
illustrated here are quantitative traits
themselves that are often negatively
correlated considering this it's
important when we're studying yield to
break it down into its individual
components looking specifically at
kernel way in kernel morphology this is
largely controlled by the grain filling
characteristics such as how long a
variety of is photosynthetically active
in the field as well as the physical
parameters of the kernels themselves
such as their length and their width and
those are both under independent genetic
control um when we're developing a new
variety the kernel weight and shape are
important traits to consider because
they both can impact I can mention final
yields but also the flour yield which is
both going to be bottom
Namah client's for a grower and a mill
and selecting variety returning though
to the more elusive characterization of
the genes that underlie these traits the
wheat community has recently had some
the release of new tools that are going
to allow us to go beyond QTL
associations and actually pursue fine
mapping and cloning of those traits
those include the release of a fully
annotated wheat reference sequence
genome as well as the prospects of gene
editing and tools like CRISPR we can
pursue the fine mapping and positional
cloning of yield components the wheat
cap or coordinated agricultural project
aims to do just this
it's a concerted effort across 15
land-grant universities to identify
genes that control different yield
components and then implement them in to
meet breeding programs
Cornell is a part of this effort and
specifically in the sorro's lab we're
looking to identify genes that impact
kernel weight and kernel shape to do
this we're using a by parental
population across between the spring
wheat variety is w seven nine eight four
or synthetic W seven nine eight four and
OPM 85 and those have formed mapping
reference populations we have access to
double tap lloyd's as well as the large
population of recombinant inbred lines
and previous work in the soils lab
indicated to us that there were grain
morphology traits on the group five
chromosomes but our challenge now is to
zoom in on those and identify the
positional gene architecture and
physical positions of causal variants to
do this we have a two pronged approach
we can first validate the QTL across
environments and locations and gears
using the double complex and then we can
gain finer resolution and pursue fine
mapping by using heterogeneous inbred
families these are essentially near
isogenic lions differ at the QTL we
develop them from selecting recombinant
inbred lines that were segregating for
the QTL or regions of interest and then
have continuously inbred them so they're
largely fixed across the genome but have
either perennials allele at the QTL as a
control for our purposes or they're
segregating which will allow us to
identify key recombination events that
are associated with our positive trait
of interest all of these plants are
filled grown we've been working with the
double-top Lloyd's and the hits in the
field since 2016 and they're planted
rows for the double top Lloyds but we
have to plant the individual spaced
planted rows because they're segregating
again and we tagged them individually as
you can see here so we can keep track of
them for all of our phenotype and
genotyping purposes the genotyping this
is a largely are the synthetic a pot of
population is widely used in the wheat
breeding community so we've access to a
lot of public resources for genotyping I
specifically have been doping cast
markers which are a fluorescent step
marker for targeting more specific
regions associated with our QTL the
genotyping which is cut off here is all
done post harvest and we harvest all the
plants individually and take a
representative hundred kernel sample
which is a proxy for thousand kernel
weight and then we also take that same
sample and scan it on a flatbed scanner
and take the kernel width and length
parameters which is what you can't see
written right there
and then all of our phenotype engine
type correlations I've been using are
QTL at this point we've identified TTL
on chromosomes 2 D 5 a 5 B and 60 that
are significantly associated with
thousand kernel weight and or the width
and the length but I want to draw your
attention to chromosome 5 um there is a
mega base pair stretch on the long arm
that is significantly associated with
thousand kernel weight and kernel width
this region is more highly annotated
than what I'm showing you here but for
today's purposes I just want to mention
that it is fully fixed across the double
top woods we either have a pot or the
synthetic alleles for all of these
markers but within the hips
it's segregating and that's going to
allow us to pursue the further find
mapping
our QTL then provides us with a lot
score or logarithm odds which is a
measurement of significance between a
genetic marker and a physical trait that
we've measured here in dark blue we have
across this 140 mega base pair region
the LOD score significant values 4000
kernel weight and in light blue that's
going to be for the width measurements
and consistently we break our threshold
significance level of 3 now I want to
show you the parental associations for
these alleles and which parents allele
is the positive donor for these traits
we can do that by breaking the double
tabloid population into two groups based
on whether they carry the synthetic
allele or the APOD allele across 140
mega base pair region and looking
specifically here at the thousand kernel
8 distribution thousand kernel a is on
the x-axis and we've broken the
population into two groups with a pata
alleles across the locus and pink or
synthetic and blue and on average we see
a 4.4 percent increase in thousand
kurtal wait for double tabloid lines
that carry the pata allele rather than
the synthetic and we see a similar story
when we look at the width distributions
here width is on the x-axis and again
there's 3.75 percent increase in kernel
widths associated with double tabloid
lines that carry the PATA allele rather
than the synthetic at our locus I
mentioned previously that kernel lengths
can also independently impact kernel
weight and so here you see at our locus
there's little to no difference in
kernel length for whether a double
haploid plant carries either parents
allele which indicates to us we're
pursuing a gene in this region that
controls thousand kernel e most likely
due to an increase in kernel width our
ultimate goal is to be introducing these
genes into varieties that farmers like
to grow we're doing this simultaneously
by back crossing the genes as we
continue to find map them into elite
varieties ground by domestic farmers as
well as through the caps collaboration
with cement and we'll continue to pursue
the identification
candidate genes and then further
identify and validate the gene
architecture through mutant populations
and then potentially gene editing if
that suits our purposes a challenge that
I mentioned is that the double tabloid
population has limited resolution but if
we return to our methodologies and
strategies I can develop cast primers
that target recombination events at our
QTL taking place in the segregating half
population over 200 hit plants are
harvested from the field this summer and
they've been genotyped and I mean the
process of phenotyping those and those
correlations will lay a strong
foundation for the continuous fine
mapping of these traits and our field
plantings this summer with that I'd like
to say thank you to the many advisers
that I have on this research and would
be happy to answer any questions
[Applause]
question
for the distributions of kernel width it
appeared like this bimodal yeah thing
going on do you have an explanation for
that is there another gene segregating
for some reason there are there may be
um I've noticed as well when we work
with this population in the field it's
really diverse there's a lot of
different phenotypes and I'm sure there
is something that we aren't catching I
also mentioned just how complex field is
and there's many different traits
affecting it as we grow fewer plants
that were more confident in the region
of the gene I hope that we can take
further phenotypes that might account
for some of those effects but I'm not
sure what trait is causing that any
other questions
all right let's give another room this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu